i've been hoping for permanent daylight  saving time and unfortunately the bill  has hit the wall it seemed that this was  going to cross party lines and everybody  wanted it it was just going to happen it  was happening  and then all of a sudden it is stalled i  think it's the best now i know some  people will say but david sir they come  to me with tears in their eyes and they  say david sir  aren't you worried it'll be dark in the  morning no it'll be dark in the morning  but i'm not worried but that extra hour  of light at the end of the day  particularly in those dark winter nights  i think it would be absolutely fantastic  if you are against permanent daylight  saving time  let me know why i want to hear it